one thing i want to talk about is the
duration of how long to take vitamin d
as well as the dosage there's a lot of
confusion most people are taking between
600 ius to a thousand i use sometimes 2
000 i use
and they think that that's enough
one thing you need to realize is that
about 75 percent of the population
on planet earth are deficient in vitamin
d
and vitamin d is so important in fact
it's the most
important fat soluble vitamin especially
for the immune system
based on some pretty credible studies
which i'm going to list down below
and i only listed three i'm gonna give
you quite a few of them
in the first study the group took a
thousand to two thousand ius of vitamin
d
once to twice per week for one month and
did not
increase their vitamin d levels at all
second study
took a thousand to two thousand ius and
it took four
months to elevate their vitamin d and in
the third study it took
three months to achieve just the normal
level of vitamin d
by taking 1600 ius of vitamin d
and i just had a call from a lady on my
live show who was taking 50
000 ius of vitamin d for
weeks and it did not even increase
her levels so the question is how could
you be that deficient if you're taking
so much vitamin d the first thing to
know is that
it takes a lot longer than you think to
fix a vitamin d deficiency
it could take months the second thing to
know
is that there are various things that
prevent the absorption of vitamin d
one is your gut if your gut has damaged
you're not going to be able to absorb
vitamin d too well also your age
greatly influences your ability to
absorb vitamin d
not just from dietary sources but from
the sun
the color of your skin also influences
your ability to absorb vitamin d
in other words if the skin is darker it
could take three times as much
sun to penetrate the skin and then
there's a topic of how much fat you have
the more subcutaneous fat you have in
your body
the less you're going to absorb vitamin
d
and then there's exposure to the sun if
you're going out in the sun
and you're only exposing your hands and
your face to the sun
you're only exposing five percent of
your body to the sun
which it would take you hours and hours
and hours
to even achieve a small amount of
vitamin d and then you have the location
where you live
the latitude the connection between
where you live in the sun
if you live in the northern hemisphere
which if we look at united
states is just above la and we look at
the months between
november and march the amount of vitamin
d you're going to get is
pretty much insignificant and then we
have metabolic issues
let's say for example you have diabetes
you have arthritis you have high blood
pressure
cardiovascular disease guess what the
requirements
for vitamin d go way way up and then of
course we have the season
if it's winter and you're out there
trying to get sun the odds of you
getting
enough vitamin d are very very slim and
then lastly there's a genetic
factor involved called polymorphism
where there is a variant or an
alteration
in your genes which don't allow you to
absorb vitamin d very well
and a lot of people have this and they
don't even know they have it and that
could be the reason why
they can't absorb it oh and there's one
more that i forgot to mention
if you have a chronic infection see the
viruses
that invade the body downgrade your
vitamin d receptor
so if you have an infection whether it's
in the lung
in the sinuses or in your gut the
microbes specifically viruses have a
strategy of blocking the absorption of
vitamin d
they block the receptor so you can't
absorb it it's a survival mechanism
and the white blood cells that are
fighting the virus
need vitamin d desperately so they're
going to suck up that last little bit of
vitamin d that you have
so as you can see there's a lot of
factors involved with the absorption of
vitamin d
how much vitamin d would i recommend 10
000 i use per day as a maintenance
and i mentioned this plus if there's an
autoimmune
issue involved and you're going to need
much higher amounts of vitamin d with
magnesium
b6 and zinc and there's a couple other
things that you can do
if you're concerned that this amount of
vitamin d is toxic which is not
you'd have to consume one to two hundred
thousand ius
of vitamin d for months and months or
years
to create the complications and the
biggest complication
from vitamin d toxicity is hypercalcemia
that's too much calcium in the blood
because that could lead to kidney stones
one way to even minimize the risk for
that would be to drink
2.5 liters of water per day that way you
avoid a
super concentration of calcium in the
kidney
so there won't be any calcium forming in
the kidney
another way is just to avoid calcium and
supplements
as well as cheese that way there's no
calcium to
go into the kidney and form as a kidney
stone all right guys thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto
there's no suffering in keto absolutely
not karen and it's an immune system
builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it